when you think about this correlation um
talk to me a little bit about the
there's decoupling right so like the
correlation goes down uh there's also
this idea that like tech socks could
just explode people go kind of risk on
again uh it sounds like you think the
decoupling is more likely to be uh what
happens than like there's a recovery in
risk assets is that fair
yeah um so i think you know for btc to
to move up you know just from first
principles you need either one of two
things and it boils down to either a you
need tech stocks to rebound and that
would drag btc up if we have the
sustained period of high correlation
the other way btc can move up would be
if that correlation broke down um and so
with that in mind i think for the for
the latter i mean for the former talking
about tech stocks rebounding i think
darius actually did a really good job
and i'm not going to get into that
because
i think he was he really nailed it on
the head he's more the expert in that
realm let's talk about like what it
would take for tech stocks to rebound um
one of the biggest things obviously just
being like the fed being extremely
hawkish
but for the decoupling piece i think
that's where i could maybe provide
listeners a bit more value with some
kind of bitcoin-centric data points um
and so like for this decoupling to
theoretically
occur
um you know i think first first just
highlighting the fact that markets move
in kind of these pendulum swings what i
mean by that is like they go from
extreme to extreme and this happens not
only with price action but also like
narratives and trends in the market and
the trend obviously we talk about here
is is the correlation to nasdaq so i
mean when you go back and look at the
chart whenever the correlation gets
extremely high uh you could even see
this at the beginning of this year it
went from getting to an all-time high
and then came all the way back down to
negatives and so you get this kind of
pendulum swing that goes back and forth
and when everyone when everyone on
twitter is talking about you know this
correlation and it becomes consensus
that tends to be when that that pendulum
is beginning to start to swing the other
direction so i think that's one thing
just to keep like preset in your mind
the fact that we've had this prolonged
sustain of regime of strong correlation
to the nasdaq um so but for that for
that decoupling to occur you need either
like two things either in the short term
some type of idiosyncratic flow meaning
you know some like large buyers stepping
in uh the luna foundation guard and
dokon stepping in and buying uh this you
know several billion dollars in btc has
been one example of that um you know
sailor was another example
so i think you know if you had some
large entity that stepped in um that
could drive idiosyncratic flow in the
short term and cause btc to to decouple
in the short term i think from the from
a broader sense and and
um
this i have a bit more high conviction
on because you know it's hard to say is
a large buyer going to step in or not
in a broader sense i think what the data
is showing you is that
beneath the surface you have a lot of
these um crypto native high net worth
individual kind of forward-looking
institutions that are viewing btc as a
store of value and you know despite all
of the uncertainty we've got
geopolitically and just mark in markets
in general um you're seeing several
metrics which we'll we'll look at the
charts in a moment um illustrating the
fact that these holders are just holding
right and so you kind of have this
dichotomy of
a lot of these traditional finance
entities that are viewing btc as you
know a high data tech asset uh and then
these convicted crypto natives um or
just people that understand the value
proposition of bitcoin and they're
holding you know during this time of
uncertainty this is the time that you
know bitcoin was built for right we have
inflation extremely high geopolitical
uncertainty um and so i think what's
kind of going on beneath the surface is
uh my buddy suzu eloquently kind of
phrased this to me as like a supply
gentrification and i think you kind of
have this um transfer of supply from
that one basket of entities i talked
about to the other
and so i think kind of this sideways
range that we've been in is an
illustration of equilibrium between the
transfer of the two of those entities
and so i guess with that we could dive
into a few of the charts that i have to
kind of back up that thesis so let's do
this idea of uh how much supply hasn't
moved in the last 12 months um and
you're comparing the seven-day moving
average uh off of the nasdaq high we
were just talking about a bunch of
stocks just
getting actually decimated uh in the
stock market so what's this showing us
yeah so in green you're looking at the
seven day moving average of the nasdaq
uh the percentage of of the nasdaq off
its highest
and so
you can see right now we're about 18
percent roughly or today might be closer
to 20
um i haven't looked at what the nasdaq's
doing in the last like 45 minutes
because i've been writing the newsletter
um
but i know i know it's down today so it
might be down closer to 20
point is though nasdaq down fairly
substantially at the same time you have
an all-time high in the amount of supply
that hasn't moved in at least a year and
that's that orange line
or i should say orange kind of area or
shaded area
and so this is honestly pretty
remarkable when you think about it right
you have an all-time high amount of
supply that hasn't moved in at least a
year meaning people are sitting on their
btc convicted as ever despite all the
uncertainty we have that we just kind of
described darius did a great job
describing earlier today um and so
to me what this is showing is that
there's this hodler base right this
convicted toddler base that they're just
they view btc as their store value
i think you know a lot of kind of um
there's there's been several catalysts
even just this year um
you know for example russia getting
their fx reserve frozen maybe it's just
inflation running high or just over the
last year as bitcoin ran up people
taking interest in understanding the
value prop of bitcoin um the fact that
you've got this growing hodler base
and i i think this is honestly pretty
remarkable the fact that you have people
holding with conviction to this extent
uh despite all the uncertainty and this
is exactly what you know bitcoin was
built for hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time